wrestling you guys are into that right
yeah cutting away have you ever did you
wrestle in like high school or anything
like that no I just like watching guys
beat the [ __ ] out of each other it's
tough though they all have Eating
Disorders after it yeah I grew up with
eating disorders and like whenever I
meet a wrestler I'm like we've been
through the same thing yeah like they
all have like teenage girl eating
disorders because of cutting weight yeah
yeah they've all and being obsessed with
every little pound and you know because
it's got kind of the same thing as like
being a teenage girl with it but trying
to obsess over like if I get to this
number it'll be I'll qualify for this
yeah group of girls to hang out with or
whatever it is damn that's crazy onto
lighter stuff answer your question yeah
yeah yeah and we could do that we
definitely yeah what do you think I am
oh really racist for a second can I yeah
I mean you asked me to okay
um
Cambodian wow like half that's that's
the most advanced answer I've received
in a long time that that is
I actually don't know he's never told me
he's right so I'm actually not sure if
that's right or not yeah you guys
haven't been sponsored by 23andMe yet
I'm waiting I'm waiting for it waiting
we're holding out for that exactly what
are you I don't it's a fun meme we don't
really say he's never said oh you've
never said but I was not right no we can
eliminate campus or were you right or
were you oh well this this makes it so
it's not racist because I could have
been exactly dead on yeah I can tell I
wasn't though what am I
um Irish
Canadian yes no he's Rich he's very rich
he's very rich oh I very read it yet
okay you know this guy wore Dior last
week really wait are you new rich or
were you doing I didn't buy it see they
said yeah no no way how is that rich
that's I mean well when you don't have
to buy it that's what the that's the
Paradox like when you get rich enough to
afford or famous enough to afford things
you don't have to buy anything anymore
yeah but I had to give it back I didn't
get to keep it wait you had to give it
back yes that's what they do they send
it so that you wear it on whatever
you're gonna do and then you have to
give it back the next morning they send
a messenger well you had fun cosplaying
as someone cool did you have stylists
set this up yeah okay because I have
stylists too but you pay them I paid
that's what happens to me too I I get
you pay thousands of dollars which is
worth it because they know what they're
doing and I don't know what I'm doing
but then you have to give the outfit
back and no one knows that well you
don't get to keep any of them originally
you got to Sue from Balenciaga but they
found out he was too old
I was in my head trying to figure out
that Meme of like all the equations was
happening in my head right now trying to
make that joke
yeah so they sent it to me instead yeah
Cody is really funny you said what two
stand-ups against Cody yeah yeah this is
ridiculous yeah
no no I I mean I do it but I hesitate to
give myself the seal of approval why I
didn't come up to the club so I feel
like who cares I don't know man no
you're in I think there's so much
snobbery with stand-ups and like even
when I was coming stand up I felt like I
couldn't call myself a stand-up until I
got on Last Comic Standing because then
it was like okay you can't be on the
show until you're a comic there's all
these and then if you take a comedy
class you're not really a comedian or
like you didn't start in clubs how did
you start I mean I I mean I grinded open
mics for like three years so I guess
it's like pretty much the same thing
that's it dude and I don't
I start now
go on and Instagram live and perform for
two people you go on tick like yeah
however you want to start like putting
it out there performing getting in front
of people whether it's you alone in your
room I don't care at all it you can it
can I don't know but people are so
snobby because Club Comics are poor and
they're jealous of you guys who are
making lots of money doing it other ways
and so they like to go there's this you
can never get in our club but so how
long you've been doing it well I did it
for like two three years before yeah you
can't call yourself yeah yeah yeah yeah
oh never mind everything yeah oh yeah
yeah after like I would say like five
times doing it you can be like on comic
yeah then we then we tour together for a
year and then
um so I've been on state like I've done
yes we've done like clearly a lot of
shows together but yeah I wouldn't call
myself a comedian legitimate because I
just like like stand up because you yeah
cause like I've never like performed
alone
I have but like for open mics and [ __ ]
not like actually wait you've done open
mics though yeah and done stand up on
over mics I dragged into his first open
mic it was great were you addicted to it
though like do you did you no I didn't
get I didn't get that I was just scared
of it the whole time even when we toured
I was scared every single time before we
went out I was [ __ ] my pants yeah
and then I would have this crazy like
adrenaline like nerve crash like
afterwards and it was just like this it
was a cycle of like yes I didn't enjoy
it you know I've still been on the road
for the last like year and change but
it'd be really funny when we had our
first so we went to St Louis yeah and we
have this like [ __ ] uh scar of a show
where it was like a St Louis crowds they
were just [ __ ] jabbering the whole
time drunk and not really knowing how to
behave oh they were just yeah that was
wrong and then where was it
um multi-level pageant the pageant I
think so yeah yeah yeah that's a good
that's a good venue good job guys thank
you but so
it was a lot of crowd work and like
trying to shut the crowd down and then
at some point Cody just like kind of
just looked over he's like all right go
at it and we got into the green Rapture
and he's like I know how the [ __ ] you
deal with that man that was
that was a lot last night actually I was
at the Laugh Factory and a guy went up
before me and some Heckler just the guy
was doing well too everyone liked him
and then some Heckler was just like you
don't make as much money as me like you
don't get girls like I do like just
wasn't even listening to the guy but
then just came at him and this was a
nice guy on stage and um and I had never
seen a comic do this but he pulled the
classic hack joke out of like man I
don't come to your work and knock the
dicks out of your mouth and I'd never
heard I thought that was just a thing
that
I didn't it was a thing we all agreed we
don't say but like I've heard that
before but it hit Jess's heart it's it's
funny it worked and I go oh I should you
know there's stock lines that get you
out of it but the funny part was is that
he he recovered and he looked like from
the outside you could not tell that he
was shaken by it at all but he
immediately after this interaction and
kind of like going like it didn't really
work and he was just kind of like okay
I'll well um so you know I'm I'm from
Iran and like he gets back into his act
and then he takes off his jean jacket
immediately because he starts
overheating like I've been there before
too you get this surge of adrenaline
that makes you overheat so you start
flops the flop sweat thing and it's like
I just but he looks so cool and
comfortable on the outside and I've been
that way before too you know like even
when that's the weird thing about
stand-up that I don't like is I don't
like when it's performative when you're
like freaking out in your head and
you're having to do say something other
than what you're thinking and I think
the best stand up is when you're able to
let loose and just say exactly what you
mean in the moment I hate those awkward
moments of like you say something weird
to someone and they're like I remember
one time a woman like I thought she
raised her hand to ask a question but
she just had like cerebral palsy and I
was just like man and then I was just
like oh and like what do you do like I
and so oh my God the flop sweat I'm like
taking off the tiny tank top I have like
just anything to get me out of this and
then just get it naked on stage and
change the vibe
it was just so awkward and like there's
just nowhere for you I I at that point
I'm drowning in my thoughts of I'm a bad
person I'm gonna get canceled I hurt
this person's feelings and you can't you
can't think clearly in that moment but
I'd like to try in those times my goal
is always to like if I'm joke bombs or
something I said something awkward is
just stop and say like what's true
that's gonna get me out of it
acknowledge the elephant in the room
which is like well this woman has I
think terrible is it cerebral palsy what
can you tell me what happened and like
and one time it did happen I got into
something where I was talking about
people in wheelchairs I had a joke and
this woman again raised like was like
tackled me and I go what's going on and
I think my joke was like it's funny that
we can you see a dog with wheels for
legs and you're like oh my God
you what happened to this Widow puppy
but you can't do that with people in a
wheelchair you can't be like oh my God
though yeah
why can't you say that because it's
clear that they're you know disabled did
you get hit by a car
oh I didn't need to put you down
um oh you went to Iraq oh but it turns
out I don't want to speak for disabled
people because I can't
um but
I do think that they want it is weird
that we just like see a person in
wheelchair we have to be like nothing's
different and just like and we like look
above them like you're up here I'm not
even gonna look down because I don't
want to acknowledge the thing that's so
I think that sometimes she even said and
she was like I love when people ask me
I'm like so if I saw you at the grocery
store I could just straight up go like
what happened to you and she's like yeah
I was like then what happened to you and
she's like I fell off a motorcycle I was
like oh [ __ ] and then she was like my
friends
are you a rescue
um
and I go she goes my boyfriend was
driving and I was like uh well like I
didn't want to ask but she was like and
he's and I'm like and he and she was
like he's
and I was like and it he was just
getting drinks for them so she pointed
out
God bless you oh my God
just a woman
I was talking about tattoos or something
and I go who has tattoos here and this
woman raises her hand and I go what's
yours and she said it's um my my baby's
Footprints or whatever and I go oh how
old and she was like he's gone and I'm
like why would you bring this
like where do I go with that I mean God
God love you for bringing it up I
swallowed some as well I don't know yeah
if I was a girl that's me as a
girlfriend I eat kids
I'm sorry
like you yeah exactly just like that
yeah I've had a couple stickers already
like you just like have this this surge
goes through you of like it's so
shameful because it is such a risk to
say something that might not be funny
and then that that that it's awful that
Vibe when the room just sucks out and
then they can sense it right yeah yeah
you said that you didn't notice that he
was bombing the guy that was getting
heckled whatever you didn't notice his
like energy change I could tell the
audience did it I knew because I just
knew like this was so like I knew he was
freaking out because he's a nice guy and
you could tell he doesn't have these
interact he's not like going after the
crowd Comics are like that like they
just don't they don't [ __ ] with the
crowd I don't [ __ ] with the crowd at all
oh really at all and people always
unless they're disabled yes unless
they're asking for it by being in a
[ __ ] a wheelchair
um that's what I said
well that's good guys by the way Nikki's
on tour
and there's Ada access so you're more
than welcome to pull up handicapped
access that's all I want my shows are
all crowded yeah
um well she does them in music venues
but they're still seated shows
as long as you bring your own I never
I
never
oh I I hope people have a good sense of
humor that are listening to this dude
it's over man it was nice you know what
this is a good way to go out I'm On Top